so are you no longer with Navarro
technically yeah so technically I'm not
with Navarro right now can you go back
or have you sort of maxed out or so I
technically have one more year because
I've done two years and everyone's going
back and everyone's like oh is she going
back is she going back at them are you
gonna go back eat kids
loosen is she gonna go back I just told
Monica I was like listen you if anything
ever happens just know I'm I'm here I'm
your backup if someone gets hurt
or if something it was to come up and
let's say someone was not able to do it
I would always but that's the only way
you would go back someone faked an
injury I mean it's kind of like it's I'm
like I'm much okay but yeah as I right
now I mean I'm cheering at Top Gun and
it's like an hour from my house and it's
in Miami and I love it it's very fun and
it's all stars so we don't go against
Navarro but okay it's really really fun
well I do want to know so you will not
compete at Daytona 2020 Oh sounds like
she's gonna go back
[Laughter]
so maybe yes uh are you guys gonna
compete at Daytona
walk me through what the rules are
because you said you can go for two
years but I think people have questions
about how many competitions can you do
at Daytona can you walk us through just
kind of how it works so technically you
have five years to compete on the
bandshell okay do you get multiple
associate's degrees then like can you
get mm-hmm
no okay you can just take that long to
get one degree yeah yeah got it setting
the record straight right yourself yeah
it's kind of crazy though like that you
only get five years cuz like if you did
let's say Navarro and then you went to a
university you have four so it should be
like six I yeah it should be six yeah so
do you guys see yourselves beam at
Navarro by the time you're done for a
total of five years I guess you can't
really answer that no well this would be
your last year yeah this is it our
government it would be everybody's it
isn't a university and we don't have
four or five years it's only the top is
three years yeah
it's just crazy because like all of us
spent every single day together when I
tell you we are like a family
we literally practice together we have
sleepovers together we go out to eat
together it's like we're seeing each
other all the time and I'm like okay
maybe it's so much too much like
brothers and sisters
yeah there's time we spend together like
eventually you get sick of each other
but then you're finally brothers and
sisters and then you and then you are
like
and that showed of the documentary how
long do you see yourself at Navarro I
think this is my last year but I'm not
gonna speak on that into it until you
know they talked about this in the
docu-series about how the life of a
cheerleading career isn't like the NFL
or the NBA so what do you guys see next
for yourselves like what's the dream
personally for me I've always had a huge
passion for art and I love drawing I
love painting I just recently got an
additional art and I love design so like
no matter what I do I know that I want
to like let my creative side show and
I'm not truly gonna I'm not gonna settle
for a career where I don't get to like
put my artwork out there sure and you're
really good we saw some of it great
yeah Jerry um well chilling is my
passion it has been ever since I was a
baby
um so I will forever be in the chair
industry whether I'm coaching or being a
choreographer a judge and I'm gonna be
in the chip world forever
thank you thank you so much
but since the show came out has been off
a lot of doors have open and so many
opportunities that Met thrown my way so
I'm gonna do my best to seize them but I
always remember where my passion lies
and this was cheers so do you think
Monica will hire you honestly I feel
like what Jerry was saying there's been
a lot of doors that have been opened and
honestly as long as I'm passionate about
it I I'm down to do whatever and
wherever life takes me
I do love like the movie industry and
all the you know action II things and I
used to talk about wanting to be a stunt
double oh yeah yeah it's I know it's
like a little dangerous and risky but
like I'm very I think I'm very very
courageous and I think that yeah
would you want a season two I wouldn't
be opposed I mean yeah it's a I think
the first season obviously I mean it's a
hit
and I think the whole country can agree
I feel like everybody's talking about it
so of course I you know I think a season
two would be amazing I think it's super
hard because it's so like the season one
is so good so it's like oh how are we
gonna top season one but seriously it's
we'll see do you think they should ever
follow a different school if there was
it to be another town know if we're
gonna be super honest I have cheered at
so many places and I feel like there is
nothing like tomorrow and that is true
there is nothing like it
yeah and until you're like actually a
part of it
you don't like understand how special it
is
[Music]